bonsoir jeudi 3 septembre bienvenue dans
le journal de la rédaction de tv 78 tout
de suite les titres de cette édition
le party les républicains fait sa
rentrée demain dans les yvelines deux
jours d'échangés de tables rondes au
port-marly avec une volonté affichée le
rassemblement un rendez vous placé aussi
sous le signe de la jeunesse l'occasion
d'évoquer l'engagement militant dans le
département
le réseau des kivus vous allez le voir
dans un instant qui a fait également sa
rentrée avec le passage aux horaires
d'hiver depuis le 31 août des nouveautés
aussi pour les lignes plus de dessert
des cours supplémentaires ou encore des
accès renforcé pour les personnes à
mobilité réduite le point à suivre et
puis à versailles exit le mois molière
en juin dernier en raison de lakovic 19
à la place le festival plaisirs d'été a
débuté dans la cité royale depuis le 25
août 13 jours autour du théâtre et de la
musique
mais avant de développer ces titres le
déplacement cet après midi de florence
parly dans les yvelines la ministre des
armées s'est rendu au lycée militaire de
saint cyr l'école accompagné de la
ministre déléguée geneviève darrieussecq
elles ont visité les locaux sont
accueillis les élèves en cette semaine
de rentrée l'établissement qui pour
rappel est en pleine phase de travaux de
modernisation
et puisqu'on parle de rentrée la carte
scolaire des yvelines a été arrêté à
retenir trente et une ouverture et six
fermetures de classes dans le
département et décision prise suite à un
groupe de travail entre le directeur
académique et les organisations
syndicales
deux jours de tables rondes et des
changes au pire amis de port marly le
rendez vous de la jeunesse se tiennent
les rendez vous de la jeunesse se
tiennent et demain et samedi mille
jeunes des républicains devraient être
présents pour cet événement dont le
parti de droite profite pour faire sa
rentrée on en parle avec geoffroy taxe
de keating bonsoir vous êtes le maire
les républicains de la commune du
perray-en-yvelines vous êtes aussi le
responsable des jeunes au sein de la
fédération les républicains des yvelines
alors un mot et prenez pour ce
rassemblement il a été dit par christian
jacob c'est le rassemblement
pourtant ce même week-end le député du
vaucluse julien aubert organise son
propre événement de son côté il ya eu
aussi à la semaine dernière ses
universités d'été organisé par bruno
retailleau à la baule laurent wauquiez
aussi proposer son propre rassemblement
aux homos mais au mont mézenc qu on a
plutôt l'impression que c'est une
rentrée en ordre dispersé pour les
républicains
alors il ya toujours eu et chaque année
yatuu rude et est rentré un peu dispersé
il ya turu l'événement de la baule mais
le grand rassemblement de la droite le
grand rassemblement des républicains
évidemment c'est le rassemblement de
port marly le 4 et 5 septembre avec tous
les ténors de v républicain qui seront
présents ici ont jacob et gérard larcher
françois baroin bruno retailleau qui
donc comme vous l'aviez dit avait déjà
fait sa rentrée donc tout le monde sera
là rassemblés et puis c'est surtout le
rassemblement de la jeunesse qui tient à
le dire puisque on a beaucoup oeuvré
pour avoir tous les jeunes qui viennent
donc ça sera surtout redonner la parole
aux jeunes au sein de ses ateliers
on aura l'occasion d'en parler tout à
l'heure le l'objectif on peut dire aussi
c'est lancer cette reconstruction de la
droite bien sûr la reconstruction de la
droite on l'a fait quand même depuis de
longs mois
je crois qu'on n'est pas dans les
guerres de personnes c'est vraiment une
reconstruction par le terrain j
christian jacob avait lancé les forums
qui a été une grande consultation des
adhérents sur de larges thématique on a
fait exactement la même chose entre
jeunes on a lancé un laboratoire d'idées
le lab et l'eire qui a permis de créer
de nombreuses lésions conférences des
ateliers des groupes de travail on a
fait venir des intervenants où les
jeunes ont exprimé leurs idées parce que
le but c'était vraiment d'alimenter le
parti on idée redonner la parole
directement aux adhérents aux militants
et plus largement à la droite et à la
jeunesse de droite et peut-être
construire aussi plus largement on est
peut-être étonné de voir qu'à
l'ouverture cet événement demain en plus
de christian jacob et de pierre bédier
il est aussi valérie pécresse qui figure
sur le programme la présidente de la
région qui a claqué la porte de votre
parti qui a fondé son propre mouvement
libre c'est aussi reconstruire large au
sein des républicains entre la
république en marche et le rassemblement
national entre jeff je crois que valérie
pécresse n'a jamais réellement quitté la
droite on peut le voir qu'est la région
ile de france
elle a une en tout cas elle reste à
droite elle a une majorité de droite et
une majorité qui est constitué
essentiellement des républicains au sein
de son conseil régional christian jacob
a fait part de sa volonté de soutenir
aussi valérie pécresse pour les
prochaines échéances électorales
je crois qu'il faut savoir se montrer
rassemblé valérie pécresse fait partie
des talents comme il y en a de nombreux
au sein des républicains la droite seul
unie et rassemblée pour a remporté ces
élections on a pu le voir qu'elle est
encore dans le coeur des français dont
la vie aux élections municipales où la
droite a largement remporté ces
élections dans des bastions où elles
étaient implantées et puis dans de
nouveaux également est ce que ça fasse
cette reconstruction de la droite avec
une alliance avec emmanuel macron c'est
en tout cas ce que veut christian
estrosi le maire de nice des propos qui
ont pu choquer au sein de votre parti à
christian jacob a dit voilà que c'était
inenvisageable qu'est ce que vous en
avez pensez vous des propos du maire
christian estrosi
je crois que
c'est pas du tout le bienvenu à 600
jours de l'élection présidentielle c'est
pas du tout le sujet des français
aujourd'hui on est vraiment dans cette
reconstruction le débat des personnes
viendra plus tard comment on peut déjà
dès à présent deux ans avant une
élection rendent les armes et dire que
l'on n'aura pas notre candidat on fait
d'abord ce travail de fond le temps de
l'incarnation viendra et puis c'est à ce
moment là que les français jugeront
je crois que emmanuel macron comme l'a
dit christian jacob n'est pas le
candidat de la droite
il vient il a été secrétaire général
adjoint à l'elysée
il a été ministre de françois hollande
et puis aujourd'hui on voit ses
faiblesses le on a vu les gilet jaune on
a vu de nombreuses manifestations contre
la politique d' emmanuel macron qui ne
répondent en rien à l'économie on n'a
jamais été aussi endetté on n'a toujours
pas retrouvé notre souveraineté
alimentaire notamment sur l'écologie on
a de nombreuses faiblesses et puis sur
l'autorité de l'état
et puis les dérives islamique je crois
que on a aimé ma cour n'a pas montré
qu'il était de droite et on l'a compris
et vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure que la
reconstruction passe par les jeunes
justement les jeunes impliqués en
politique on a décidé d'élargir un petit
peu le spectre est pas se limiter aux
républicains avec nicolas landry
bonsoir de la rédaction de tv soixante
dix huit sur l'engagement politique des
jeunes dans le département des yvelines
déjà quels sont les différents partis
politiques qui sont présents auprès des
jeunes dans les yvelines et bien grégory
nous avons répertorié au moins un set
groupes politiques vous allez les voir
apparaître à l'image on retrouve les
jeunes républicains les jeunes avec
macron génération nation soixante dix
huit pour le rassemblement national un
mouvement qui a changé de nom mais qui
est né avec le front national dans les
années 70 dans le département nous avons
aussi des jeunes générations point s du
mouvement créé par benoît hamon en
juillet 2017
il ya aussi les jeunes communistes le
mouvement des jeunes socialistes des
yvelines relancer au mois d'août puisque
ce mouvement était en sommeil depuis les
élections de 2017 et enfin les jeunes
démocrates du modem
concernant les mouvements jeunes de la
france insoumise et d'europe écologie
les verts
tout se passe finalement au niveau
régional
qu'est ce que c'est être aujourd'hui 1
jeunes engagés politiquement ragen
engagé politiquement en moyenne entre 15
et 30 ans c'est un militant engagé sur
le terrain pour recueillir les
revendications des citoyens comme un
relais pour le parti c'est aussi un
engagement pour des valeurs des idées et
une idéologie politique défendue par
leur parti on va les écouter
aujourd'hui on a un gouvernement pour
lequel on a vraiment envie de se battre
qui en fait défend énormément les
intérieurs de la jeunesse faire remonter
des informations erronées des jeunes mis
en contact avec des jeunes
on doit faire remonter au gouvernement
et aux élus locaux
c'est pas les enjeux aujourd'hui de plus
mais ce une motivation déjà son traître
à contretemps liés à des inégalités
sociales et économiques grandissantes
les jeunes s'engagent dans notre
mouvement ont lutté contre un système
qui exploite les pauvres au profit des
plus riches alors à côté de leurs
convictions certains jeunes s'engagent
aussi pour leur avenir l'évolution de la
société on l'a vu notamment avec les
manifestations des lycéens pour défendre
l'environnement
on les écoute je pense qu'en tant que
jeune on a des on a des vrais sujets de
mobilisation je pense par exemple aussi
à l'écologie c'est bête mais on nous on
est la génération qui va devoir vivre en
fait avec le dérèglement climatique qui
va devoir trouver les réponses à ce
problème là l'état de déliquescence
l'état d'insécurité puis même de faim de
deux fractures sociales dans notre pays
on peut pas en étant je pense jeunes
restés inactifs face à cela parce que
c'est quelque chose qui va nous
concerner directement
voilà pour ce tour d'horizon pour les
mouvements jeunes dans les yvelines
geoffroy max de keating vous l'avez dit
un tout à l'heure dans l'entretien avec
grigoriy vous souhaitez participer à la
refondation du parti des républicains
participer au programme de 2022 comment
les jeunes républicains peuvent
participer avec quelle idée notamment
les jeunes ont aujourd'hui un jeune de
droite
il manifeste sa volonté de d'opérer
vraiment une transition écologique
positive ça a été un sujet qui a été
largement relayé le climat l'écologie je
crois que la bonne approche c'est la
proche de tous les français la proche
que demandent les jeunes c'est de
d'inciter à
opéré cette transition écologique
d'avoir une approche pragmatique et
positive ne plus être dans la punition
un jeune de droite pour refonder son
parti ils demandent de la liberté je
demande qu'on ait plus de libertés
individuelles
il demande également de la réussite
qu'on l'aide à réussir pas qu'on nivelle
par le bas mais qu'on lui donne les
moyens de cette réussite qui croient en
la méritocratie gros travail
il croit en l'ascenseur social voilà
globalement ce que demande aux jeunes de
droite et c'est ce que demandent
aujourd'hui nos jeunes dans notre parti
et c'est sur ça qu'ils veulent
la refondation de la droite ils veulent
de l'autorité également de l'état ils
veulent retrouver cette sécurité ils
veulent un avenir paisible et il faut
leur donner les moyens de réussir ça et
ne pas les bris mais c'est tout ce que
l'on demande mais on l'a compris un les
jeunes républicains qui seront
pleinement engagés demain et samedi dans
ce rendez vous en cette rentrée
politique pour le parti les républicains
c'est au port marly merci geoffroy pay
the kitchen est revenu en plateau mère
du perray-en-yvelines et responsable des
jeunes les républicains 78
[Musique]
politique toujours avec une élection
législative partielle en vue le 20
septembre les électeurs de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines sont
appelés à élire leurs nouveaux députés
suite à la démission de nadia de
nombreux candidats se présentent au
scrutin et lutte ouvrière a choisi
patrick planquer des gens en liste pour
les municipales dans la ville de trappes
milani poké lots nord sinoquet engagé
depuis 35 ans patrick planquer le
candidat de lutte ouvrière pour la 11e
circonscription des yvelines ouvriers de
maintenance sncf de 52 ans il tentera de
prendre la suite de nadia est
démissionnaire après sa nomination au
sein du gouvernement ce qui manque
aujourd'hui c'est un parti des
travailleurs ce qui manque aujourd'hui
c'est une organisation des travailleurs
qui défendent ce point de vue et qui
organise à l'échelle d'un quartier à
l'échelle d'une usine à l'échelle d'un
atelier la population laborieuse et qui
défendent ce point de vue là et moi
c'est pour ça que je fais de la
politique depuis très longtemps
suppléant lors du scrutin de 2010 est il
se porte candidat la municipale de
trappes de 2020 où il obtient 3 % des
voix à l'issue du premier tour
dans cette campagne il souhaite porter
le message est la voix des travailleurs
nous ce qu'on a toujours dénoncé dans
nos campagnes et dans notre activité
militante c'est de dire oui aujourd'hui
le capitalisme il est réellement
responsable de cette situation et c'est
bien à ça qu'on s'attaque aujourd'hui et
c'est ça qu'on veut défendre en
défendant le point de vue des
travailleurs pour ce scrutin la gauche
part divisée sandrine grand gang pour
génération et valérie froberger pour la
france insoumise sont déclarés dans le
reste de l'actualité en bref une vaste
campagne de dépistage au qu'ovide 19
pour les salariés des entreprises elle
est organisée en début de semaine
prochaine au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 3000 test pca
gratuits et anonymes seront réalisées
sur place par une équipe de l'assistance
publique hôpitaux de paris les chefs
d'entreprise sont invités à se
préinscrire sur le site internet de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines inscrire leurs
collaborateurs pour faciliter les
démarches
une vague de mutilation vise les chevaux
en ce moment dans toute la france et
dans les yvelines d attaque cruelle qui
ont ciblé aussi d'autres animaux dans la
nuit
13 au 14 mai dernier noisette une vache
laitière de la ferme de gally à saint
cyr l'école avaient été égorgées et
dépecer une autre vache sérieusement
blessé le tribunal correctionnel de
versailles vient de condamner le tueur
un homme de 34 ans à 15 mois de prison
ferme et haussier avec quinze mois de
prison ferme avec mandat de dépôt il
avait été interpellé lundi dernier par
les forces de l'ordre yvelinoise l
individu dit avoir agi sous le coup de
l'ivresse et a nié l'assassinât de trois
moutons on retrouvait aussi est mort le
21 mars dernier toujours à la ferme de
gally transport des nouveautés du côté
de ski bus le prestataire renforce
encore son réseau cette saison
prolongation de certaines lignes accès
aux pmr supplémentaires ont fait le
point avec célia et gars tsongo et
astrid bergère
cette année de nouveaux territoires sont
desservis sur les réseaux de bus de
saint quentin en yvelines pour permettre
aux 230 mille habitants de
l'agglomération et à ceux qui viennent
de s'y déplacer comme sur la ligne 4
sont deux qui relie la gare de trappes
au collège sainte-thérèse du
mesnil-saint-denis on a créé en fait une
souligne pour desservir des quartiers du
mesnil saint denis qui n'étaient pas
desservies jusqu'à présent donc en fait
aux heures de pointe vous avez plusieurs
quartiers comme bois du fait henri viii
la place henri iv les résidences du
château qui sont désormais reliées à la
gare de la verrière pour aller vous
faites prendre le train notamment la
ligne 415 elle qui part de la place
dumesnil au mesnil saint denis est
prolongée jusqu'au quartier de la croix
bonnet à bois d'arcy de façon permanente
alors qu'elle était uniquement aux
heures de pointe c'était d'abord une
demande de la ca de versailles grand
parc
par ailleurs
en fait la croix bonnet c'est un
quartier qui se développe de plus en
plus d'habitants il ya de plus en plus
d'emplois donc il est logique
d'accompagner justement l'évolution des
besoins et pour faire face à l'afflux de
personnes des courses supplémentaires
ont été ajoutées aux heures de pointe
sur la 422,7 ligne ainsi que sept autres
bénéficient désormais aussi d'un accès
pour les personnes à mobilité réduite
au total sur les 90 lignes de bus
présentes sur le réseau 35 sont
accessibles dans l'agenda du week-end ce
match de football caritatif dimanche à
poissy le variétés club de france
affronte une équipe de soignants et de
l'hôpital poissy-saint-germain-en-laye
coup d'envoi 15 heures au stade léo
lagrange de poissy côté variétés sont
annoncés d'anciennes gloires du football
bixente lizarazu christian karembeu
robert pirès ou encore arsène wenger et
yannick noah a devrait être également de
la partie les fonds a récolté pour ce
match iront à la fondation hôpitaux de
paris hôpitaux de france toujours du
football est toujours à poissy on jouait
ce mercredi soir ce mercredi soir la
troisième journée de nationale 2 en
football c'est la quatrième division
nationale au programme un derby non
entre poissy et versailles deux équipes
qui ont besoin de points en ce début de
championnat le résumé de la rencontre
michael et demi d'euros
dès les premières minutes le ton est
donné au stade léo lagrange ce derby de
nationale 2 entre poissy et versailles
sera engagée sous les yeux des trois
cents spectateurs malgré une belle
frappe en début de match les joueurs
pisciacais ce sont les visiteurs qui
dominent cette première période sans
réussite
0 0 à la pause souvent la possession du
ballon
on était assez cohérent dans ce qu'on
faisait dans tous concernent milieu de
terrain et à la proche du but on n'a pas
spécialement été très dangereux note
reproche c'est d'avoir
pas plus avoir réussi à convertir je
pense que on est tellement stressé ne
pas prendre de poids pour rester christ
est dans notre camp et qu'on balance
tout au retour des vestiaires poissy se
reprend les bleu et jaune sont proches
de marquer à plusieurs reprises mais les
joueurs manquent de réalisme et aurait
pu se faire surprendre en fin de match
comme sur ce dernier coup franc à
l'entrée de la surface de réparation le
tir passe au-dessus de la transversale
score final 0 à 0 on a plus d'occasions
franches
et c'est quelques coups d'éclat tison
mais nous céder au casot france donc je
pense que nous on doit l'emporter d'un
côté on est déçus parce qu'on aura
beaucoup d'occasions france et d'un
autre côté satisfait parce qu'on prend
le premier point on a souffert et puis
après on sait les situations que nous
avons eues solliciations d' attaques
rapides
on avait quand même deux trois approches
à voir également une occasion
très franches et on aurait pu
éventuellement convertir sur une
interrogation mieux négocier après cette
rencontre poissy pointe à la dernière
place du classement de nationale 2
versailles de son côté 7e du championnat
culture et cette mauvaise nouvelle du
côté de coignières la saison culturelle
2020 2021 est suspendu jusqu'au 31
décembre une décision de la mairie en
raison de la dégradation du contexte
sanitaire annonce la mairie dans un
communiqué à la place le théâtre le
théâtre alphonse daudet proposera des
rendez-vous d'une heure dans un cadre
sanitaire sécuriser les activités
associatives et les ateliers sont
également maintenus pour l'heure pour
refermer ce journal 13 jours de théâtre
et de musique à versailles c'est ce que
propose le nouveau festival plaisirs
d'été la manifestation remplace le
traditionnel mois molière annulé en juin
dernier est depuis le 25 août
artistes en résidence et talent se
succèdent sur la scène extérieure le
reportage de justin brasier nicolas
d'endroit sûr c'est traditionnellement
le mois molière à lui en juin
cette année la manifestation a dû être
annulée en raison de lakovic 19 pour
pallier l'impact culturel et mettre à
l'honneur les artistes
le maire de la ville a mis en place un
nouveau festival plaisirs d'été il ya eu
un vrai malaise à l'idée de se dire que
tous ces professionnels spectacle ne
pouvait plus travailler il faut être
conscient tenait main que depuis donc le
mois de mars
il ne travaille plus et je crois que
dans ces moments de grande difficulté 1
2 de tension
c'est important de maintenir une vie
culturelle
une bonne nouvelle pour le public et
versailles et qui permet de renouer avec
les artistes et le monde du spectacle
c'est ce qui m'a le plus manqué pendant
toute cette période de confinement et
des confinement et le fait qu'on ait ce
cadeau là
fin août et début septembre avec des
spectacles de plein air
c'est vraiment un très grand plaisir et
c'est très important pour moi de juin
d'habitude il ya du théâtre et des des
festivités que j'aime beaucoup et là ce
plaisir d'été est un désir de faire des
têtes après pour moi un peu plaisir
si le monde culturel a été fortement
impactée par la crise sanitaire
le virus peut devenir une force pour le
monde du théâtre c'est ce qu'expliquait
christophe barbier metteur en scène du
spectacle le tour du théâtre en 80
minutes
c'est un grand plaisir de retrouver les
spectateurs même masqué c'est pas un
problème c'est un grand plaisir de
montrer que le théâtre est plus fort que
le virus plus fort que l'épidémie ne
montrait même que le théâtre peut
participer d'une sorte de de lutte de
thérapie contre l'épidémie et toutes les
peurs qu'il ya autour
le festival plaisirs d'été a lieu
jusqu'au 6 septembre programme et
réservations sur le site festival
plaisirs d'été point fr c'est la fin de
ce journal merci de votre fidélité on se
retrouve dès lundi pour une nouvelle
édition belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]